نذكر المشاهدين انه تدور حاليا مباراه قطر
والاكوادور في اول اذن المباريات ضمن هذا
المونديال معنى الان من حديقه البدع في
كورنيش الدوحه مراسل الجزيره حمزه الراضي
حمزه ايضا البدع من مناطق المشجعين التي
وضعت فيها شاشات ضخمه لتتوفر للمشجعين هذه
المتابعه الممتعه ولكن اريد ان تنقل لنا
الاجواء وردود الفعل كيف كانت الحشود حول
نستفيد هنا من تجربتك في تغطيه ايضا كاس
العالم في روسيا
نعم مياده مساء الخير في الحقيقه الحشود
ما زالت من حولي وهذه هي منطقه المشجعين
الرئيسيه مياده كما تشاهدين الان بعد
نهايه الشوط الاول من المباراه الافتتاحيه
بين قطر والاكوادور ربما هي فرصه لهم كي
يذهبوا وياخذوا قصه من الراحه بعد
الماكولات والمشروبات التي يوفرها هذا
المكان الاجواء لم تقل الحماسيه هنا مياده
عن تلك التي يشهدها استاذ البيت الذي تدور
فيه مباراه الافتتاح كان هناك تفاعل كبير
مع حفل الافتتاح
وايضا مع كل ما تضمنه من فقرات وكان محل
همم
هذه الشاشات العملاقه التي تتزين بها
منطقه المشجعين هنا في حديقه البدعه يسجل
هنا مياده ايضا ان معظم من يوجد هنا هم من
الجاليات العربيه التي جاءت هنا لمسانده
المنتخب القطري صحيح النتيجه حتى الان
ربما تنظف قليلا هذه الاجواء الاحتفاليه
لكن مازال هنالك شوط ثاني 45 دقيقه نتمنى
ان يعود المنتخب القطري في النتيجه
الابواب هنا مياده فتحت
رابع من وقت ربنا من حفل الافتتاح كانت
الاعداد تتزايد طوابير طويله عند مدخل هذه
المنطقه همم التي نذكر بانها تغلق ابوابها
في الواحده والنصف بعد منتصف الليل على ان
تعيد وتفتح ابوابها من جديد غدا في ال
11:00 صباحا اي قبل المباراه الاولى التي
ستجرى في واحده ظهرا هذه هي الاجواء
في المكان
منذ
كيف وجدت الحماس ولا ابرز ردود الفعل
الكلمات التي كنت تسمعها من المشجعين
نعم مياده كما ذكرت يعني ذكرتي ااا تجاربا
السابقه في تغطيه المونديال يعني يكاد او
لا يخلو لا تخلو نسخه من كاس العالم
فرصه
هنا في منطقه
المشجعين نفس الحماس نفس الاهازيج كوكتيل
من الاعلام مياده من جميع
امس هنا من نفس هذا المكان وقال بان كاس
العالم في قطاره هو فرصه للتعايش فرصه
لتبادل الثقافات والحضارات سعيده همم
حسابات همم ليست لها علاقه بالرياضه نحن
هنا لكي نستمتع بالرياضه وبكره القدم
والجميع يتحدث لغه كره القدم مياده
والصوره طبعا ابلغ من اييه من اي تعليق
مياده ستتواصل هذه الاجواء كما ذكرت في
منطقه المشجعين على مدار 29 يوما حتى
نهايه المونديال